hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine lieben
zuschauer zu einem neuen video auf
meinem kanal ihr kennt wird sicherheit
fotos auf denen dieses logo hier drauf
diese bilder heißen
doch fotos topf autos sind ganz normale
bilder die von irgendwelchen fotografen
gemacht werden und dann an agenturen
verkauft werden so dass diese agenturen
sie dann weiterverkaufen können an
irgendwelche anderen leute diese bilder
haben wollen also wenn ich mir jetzt
denke ich brauche ein foto von einer
frau die was gehst dann kann ich da
quasi so stock fotos einkaufen damit ich
die dann nutzen kann versteht was ich
meine und ich war dass es eigentlich
mega cool und auch super praktisch als
wenn man selbst irgendwie foto braucht
von irgendeiner situation oder keine
ahnung was und man selbst hat sich die
zeit oder die ressourcen selbst dieses
foto zu machen kann man es dort hat
einfach kaufen und dann benutzen es gibt
allerdings auch stock fotos wo man sich
einfach denkt aim wer hat dieses foto in
auftrag gegeben und wer in gottes namen
sollte sich so eine art vom foto
überhaupt kaufen wollen und solche
bilder schauen wir uns heute gemeinsam
an und damit ihr direkt wissen wovon ich
spreche zeige ich euch direkt das erste
foto uns was ist das hier das ist eine
katzen schlange in dem kürbis fällt die
sich gerade eine suppe kocht allein darf
dieser moody's heute übrigens neu
gelaunt stellt ist der viele schnee
dieser wurde jetzt heute im luca -
shop.de rausgekommen vor einigen stunden
und diese skizzen auch einem das kissen
ist glaube ich bereits ausverkauft
leider aber es gibt auf jeden fall noch
ein ganz paar von diesen schwarzen rudi
sich glaube er weiß ist auch fast schon
ausverkauft oder in vielen größen ist
das sogar schon ausverkauft als ich
wollte mich aber an der stelle noch mal
ganz ganz toll bei euch bedanken für den
riesigen support heute um 15 uhr im shop
das hat mich mega gefreut dass diese
klamotten so mega gut bei euch an kamen
aber jetzt wieder zurück zu unserer
tollen katzen schlange ja ich weiß
wirklich nicht was man dazu sagen soll
oder vor allem auch bastian die leute
google denkt jedoch kein mensch
wahrscheinlich ja für meine projekt
dabei bräuchte ich ein foto von einer
katze aber als schlange und die soll
eine kürbissuppe gerade essen
das hier ist das nächste komisches topf
oder was sie rausgesucht habe und es ist
einfach ein junge mit einer piraten
mütze und einer cd im mund und am
computer aber auch das nächste foto ist
so komplett bescheuert ich meiner sitzt
ein
mit seinem anzug in einer vollen
badewanne und hat eine ente auf dem kopf
muss nicht aber kann man mal so macht
hier sehen wir eine schockierte katze
und sie ist schockiert darüber dass aus
ihrem computer ab warum sie auch immer
einen computer hat da kommen einfach
hände raus
ja ich glaube ihr chat langsam warum ich
das alles so mega komisch finde wer
allerdings gerade schon beim thema
katzen waren das nächste bild haben sich
ebenfalls von einer katze uns doch von
dieser hier steht vor der haustür mit
einem strauß blumen und keine ahnung was
seit der genaue hintergedanke ist
versteht mich bitte nicht falsch ich
finde es ja mega cool dass das diese
möglichkeit gibt wenn man sich denkt als
einzelperson und als unternehmen hey ich
brauche ein foto von der und der
situation könnte sich das sie kaufen und
so weiter und so fort alle seiten
profitieren aber warum will man so ein
foto beispielsweise habe ich meine das
ist eine frau tanzen dem wald und sie
spaghetti bolognese in die luft ja genau
das wurde noch wie viel für meine
doktorarbeit oder auch dass hier ein
mann in unterhose macht einer frau im
rollstuhl antrag das nächste foto ist
allerdings dass hier
er stellt sich an dem pool und dann
schmeißt er sie in den pool seines foto
hier liegt ein junger salamis in das
cd-laufwerk seines computers
ja wahrscheinlich sind deine eltern
nicht zufrieden mit und das hier ist
eine weibliche version von hitler beim
kartoffeln schälen
ich frag mich auch nichts mehr wo wir
gerade beim thema kartoffeln sind meine
lieben freunde hier
es ist eine dame am computer und lehnt
die kartoffel ab ganz alltägliche
situation und wo man will einfach noch
mal arbeit und plötzlich kommt so eine
kartoffel dann aber nein man sagt nein
zur kartoffel hier
da geht so viel vor
die frau ist auf irgendeinem corolla und
fährt vom sturm weg und man muss sie
aber anhalten weil die katzen ampel
zeigt gerade grün und da läuft eine
katze über einen zebrastreifen
und beim nächsten foto habe ich einfach
big bird gegoogelt also einen großen
vogel wollte ich das sehen und dann kam
das hier ja das ist überhaupt nicht
verstören
das hier ist irgendwie katzen version
von titanic namens cat harnik und beim
nächsten foto weiter lieben freude da
frage ich mich wirklich nichts mehr
es ist eine frau die dabei es ihren
goldfisch zu erschießen
warum in erster linie gibt man so ein
photon auftrag warum
zweitens fotografiert der fotograf ist
auch und hinterfragt das ganze nicht und
drittens warum gibt es abnehmer für
diese bilder warum existiert eine
nachfrage nach einem foto wo eine frau
kurz davor hat ihren goldfisch zu
erschießen
ich zeig dich
aber hey
kommen wir zum letzten foto und ich
zeige es euch einfach
ich
keine ahnung was er
was ich frag mich einfach wirklich gar
nicht mehr anders stellt euch das
heutige video allerdings auch beenden
beide lieben freunde wenn euch meine
reaktion auf diese komischen wtf stock
bilder whatever gefallen hat er wirklich
sehr darüber einen daumen hoch von euch
unter dem video ihr freund schreibt
immer uns in die kommentare
welches bild ihr am ersten noch gekauft
hätten also wenn ihr jetzt diese ganzen
bilder angezeigt bekommen hätte auf
einer website und die müsste durch
vereinfachte entscheiden was ihr ein
foto vor allem und ich zeig' 0
nehmen wir mal müsst euch für ein foto
entscheiden dass ihr benutzen müsste
also welches foto weiter wer das foto wo
ihr wirklich sagt das ist noch am
normalsten schreiben dass man gerne in
die kommentare da interessiert mich eure
meinung echt mega noch mal ein
dankeschön für euren riesen support für
bei dem launch heute bei den drei neuen
produktlinien shop gekommen sind
die url ist und in der beschreibung oder
halt einfach luca - shop.de würde ich
mich auch sehr freuen wenn da mal
vorbeischauen würde da abonniert gerne
einen kanal falls noch keine teller
lucio seid habt ihr bock dass ich
nochmal auf solche komischen bilder
reagieren könnte mir auch gerne dann dem
nächsten brief schreiben
ich wurde auf dem nordpol tschüss
[Musik]